pendant le confinement qui a duré deux
mois on a vu énormément de marques
d'affection envers les soignants ses
applaudissements à la fenêtre et aux
balcons que vous avez sans doute vu tous
les soirs à 20h et des musiciens eux
aussi ont décidé de dédier des chansons
assez personnelle en première ligne
pendant cette crise sanitaire du colis
de 19
miquel aknine et l'un d'entre eux
bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le directeur de l'école
de musique guitare influences qui est
situé à versailles est aussi à viroflay
vous aussi vous avez poussé la
chansonnette pour le monde médical on
écoute tout de suite un extrait dans une
main c'est certain
s'écrie notre avenir dans leurs mains un
destin celui de se courir
dans une main tout soutien l'objet de
noter ici et dans leurs mains c'est
l'humain qui donne la force de tenir
cette chanson était l'actrice appelle
dans une main racontez-nous déjà son son
histoire pourquoi avoir fait ce titre
bat tout d'abord l'inspiration de la
réalité et de ce qu'on vivait et quand
on est un artiste ou qu'on a un support
pour d'expression ben on l'utilisé pour
dire ce qu'on ressent profondément et
c'est vrai que ben dans une main
pourquoi une main parce que la main et
c'est un symbole c'est le symbole d'une
de l'action et de la bonne ou de la
mauvaise d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on dira pour cette chanson
et il a les mains étaient tellement
parlante
quand on voyait tous ces soignants la
main c'était le le prolongement du coeur
en fête prolongement de finalement de
lui mettre de l'humain qui a d'entre
tous ces soignants qui ont fait d'une
dévotion et d'une générosité d'une
disponibilité absolue et je crois qu'on
a tous été complètement à genoux devant
ça eh ben voilà donc la musique du coup
vase déjà fait ça suivi sa sa logique
c'est à dire qu'il fallait faire un truc
on a fait une chanson dans un cadre très
confiné avec les moyens du bord avec des
images d'internet libres de droits
oui je vous vois dans ce clip on voit
aussi plusieurs images d'une banque
libres de droits c'est ça voilà c'est
des images qui sont soit libre de droit
soit des images on peut acheter soit des
images qui étaient aussi issu d'un court
métrage qui avait été qui avait été
tourné par marjolaine de l'éclusé et
puis dans lequel on retrouve bruno solo
et qui était un petit court métrage qui
qui se joue à huis clos dans un hôpital
donc c'était vraiment le lien était
évident et on voit deux animateurs de
l'hôpital venir réconforter donner un
petit peu de mots aux enfants malades et
c'était aux liens effectivement avec
l'actualité aussi bon polar est plus
dans le type et puis voilà et c'est vrai
que c'est un clip voilà de l'émotion et
de et d'admiration en fait pour le corps
médical qui peuvent 100% confiné on l'a
compris les paroles à la mélodie
elles vous sont venus pendant ce
confinement vous les avez écrit de
penser pendant pendant ce confinement
ouais en partie notamment le refrain
surtout le couplet je l'avais un petit
peu en tête
on a toujours des coups de petites
musiques comme ça qui se baladent et
puis à un moment donné on trouve le
terrain de là pour leur donner vie et
c'est vrai que que c'était une ambiance
jazz un peu jazz swing jazz manouche
comme pour nous prenait beaucoup à
l'école et qu'on aime aussi transmettre
et enseigner c'est un jazz très vivant
très très touchant et avec beaucoup
d'impact mélodique et c'est vrai que je
restais un petit peu dans cette ambiance
là et ça colle bien je crois
effectivement aux messages quoi avec ce
rapport aux mains vous l'avez dit
prolongement du coeur de ces soignants
et ça permet aussi de d'évoquer les
autres professions parce que à travers
cet hommage au personnel soignant vous
souhaitez aussi rendre hommage à au
personnes qui sont en 2e 3e 4e ligne de
cette crise sanitaire
en fait
je crois dans le mot main on peut un peu
tout inclure c'est à dire qu'à travers
la main on peut rendre hommage à
effectivement à l'action en règle
générale quelle qu'elle soit et on l'a
vu à travers cette crise que
effectivement vous avez raison de le
souligner il n'y a pas que les soignants
il ya énormément de gens qui étaient qui
sans qui rien n'aurait pu pouvoir se se
se nourrir s'approvisionner en
différentes choses donc effectivement
c'est un hommage à tous ces gens là qui
ont été suis vraiment sur le front qui
ont été présents à qui on rend hommage
mais évidemment au premier lieu aux
soignants qui vraiment jouer leur vie
quoi entre moi qui donnait des cours par
skype à mes élèves et un soignant qui
est le matin avec des gants en train de
soigner ce qu'on n'est pas sur la même
sur la même jauge quoi donc
effectivement oui c'est un hommage à
l'humain stade d'abord et cette crise
révèle aussi beaucoup de choses sur
l'humain mais pas qu'eux aussi sur un
système sûr après qui peut déboucher sur
d'autres thématiques mais je crois que
mal à la main c'est ça cette solide de
la main c'est de dire qu'on peut
construire comme détruire avec cette
main et que là on a une déclaration
d'amour
enfin ces soignants un dernier mot pour
vous demander quelle est la suite pour
vous on imagine que l'école votre école
de musique et est fermé en ce moment
même si vous le dites vous continuer les
cours à distance vous espérer reprendre
les courants en physique dans les
prochains mois les prochaines semaines
en présentiel à présentiel j'ai
découvert seulement le promo présent
sièges
mais ces présidentielles mais même
présence y est c'est vrai que c'est un
mot qui redevient très court en ce
moment donc effectivement on espère
réouvrir au 1er juin en présentiel donc
avec avec nos élèves dans la mesure où
ça se passe bien au niveau du
déconfinement me suivre les choses se
passent de façon sereine et que des gens
ont bien compris toute l'histoire des
gestes barrières qu'il faut adopter et
c'est donc si tout se passe bien on
devrait réouvrir au 1er juin
voilà merci de tels actes ninja rappelle
directeur de cette école de musique
guitare influencé et auteur de ce titre
dans une main que vous pouvez
écouter en intégralité via le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec no mercy surtout à vous